[موسيقى]
جانجا
الايرانيه فن المشاركه الناعمه في الثوره
لتتحول مشاركتها الى دور رياضيا مؤثر في
الحراك الحاصل سواء داخل ايران او خارجها
[موسيقى]
حيوان
تاتي من عائله لها باع طويل في فن الطهي
اكتسبت من والديها وجديها الثقافه تقدر
اهميه الطعام في حفظ الذكريات تاريخ وطن
ابعدتهم الظروف عنه بعد نجاح مبادرتيها
هاشتاج اطبخ من اجل سوريا وهاشتاق اطبخ من
اجل اوكرانيا على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
اراده الصدفه ان تحتاج ايران لمبادره
مماثله فالاحداث الاخيره جاءت فرصه لليله
للاضاءه على جانب مختلف من بلدها من خلال
مبادره هاشتاج اطبخ من اجل ايران
مهم جدا في تعزيز التعاطف وتطوير الارتباط
بالثقافه لانه شيء يستطيع الناس الاستمتاع
به كجزء من الثقافه والطعام الايراني
متنوع جدا من ناحيته التوابل والمكونات
واجد انه قادرا على اعطاء منظور مختلف عن
الشعب الايراني ولما يجري في ايران
شارك في حمله هاشتاج اطبخ من اجل ايران
حتى الان المئات من صناع المحتوى على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بالاضافه الى نحو
30 شافا محترفا من مختلف انحاء العالم من
بينهم عماد الارنب صاحب ومطبخ عماد السوري
في العاصمه لندن الذي يشارك فيها هاشتاج
اطبخ من اجل ايران من خلال طبق جولي معزا
لانه هي ورده فجرت هي زهره فجرت ثوره اذا
فيك تقولي
ضوت ضوت على قضيه انسانيه
دوت على حقوق المراه يلي
احيانا بتكون مهمشه وهذا وهذا الشيء اللي
سويته عملته
وضلت وظلت كذلك
منذ ايام حياته في سوريا كما انه من رواد
المشاركين في مبادرات الانسانيه طوال
رحلتي لجوءه من سوريا حتى وصوله الى
بريطانيا
اعداد وجبه يطعمك هذه ربما من افضل الطرق
التضامن الثقافي في العالم فلذا الطوهاتي
مثل عماد ميزته خاصه وهي الاضاءه على
الجانب الاجمل لبلدان تركوها قصرا من خلال
اشتراك الناس في قضاياها السياسيه
والاجتماعيه من خلال فن الطبخ العربيه